the matrix is one of the most
influential action movies of all time
but by mixing stylish Goong who fight
scenes with cyberpunk themes it builds
to a trilogy that may have left a few
moviegoers a little confused now that
we've got some distance from the
climactic installment let's take a look
back at the movies meaning and breakdown
the conclusion here's the ending of the
Matrix trilogy explained one major theme
that came to the fore is the series
reached its conclusion
had to do with the similarities between
humans and machines in the original they
couldn't seem more different but by
revolutions programs in the matrix are
portrayed as being almost more human
than our heroes loving and happy
individuals as worthy of existence as
any person further characters from the
first film who were firmly human or
machine or portrayed in the sequels as
having a little bit of both
the similarities go in both directions
Agent Smith a program copied his
consciousness onto a human form entering
the real world through the vessel of a
resistance fighter named Bain neo a
human reached the source to discover
that being the one was his destiny
because it was programmed into him the
humanizing of the machines and the
complementary mechanization of neo made
for a storytelling turn that audiences
weren't really ready for people who saw
the Matrix couldn't be faulted for
expecting an ending that saw neo winning
by doing his Superman thing and
eradicating humanity's robot overlords
instead neo triumphed by becoming a
bridge between man and machine
sacrificing his own life for the sake of
security in the future
he also made Hugo Weaving 's head
explode but that wasn't quite as
important one widespread but inaccurate
theory about the sequels is that the
real world is actually a second Matrix
while the reasons why this isn't true
are explained in the movies they're also
relatively easy to misunderstand the
real world isn't another level of the
matrix but it is involved in another
system of control as the architect
explains at the ending of the Matrix
Reloaded each version of the matrix is
propped up in the real world by a
controlled rebellion with each new
iteration of the matrix a select portion
of the population is free allowed to
live in Zion there they help to liberate
people inside the matrix searching for
the one finding the one the human rebels
rally behind him supporting him until
they reach the source there the one
discovers that they are not meant to
destroy the matrix but rather restart it
at this point in the cycle the machines
attacked Zion and destroy it killing the
rebellion the one having reached the
source is made to choose between either
reloading the matrix and selecting a
handful of survivors to build a new Zion
or walking away
supposedly causing a system crash
leaving the humans inside and outside of
the matrix all dead
up until neo everyone made the choice to
restart perpetuating the system of
control because neo loves Trinity he
chooses to sacrifice everything to be
with her this is the choice that makes
him special proponents of the second
Matrix theory support it by pointing to
the powers neo is able to manifest in
the sequels real world being able to see
without eyes and exert control over
approaching sentinels for a lot of
viewers this breaking of the rules
almost felt like a betrayal with the
audience having been made to believe
that neo could only manifest these
superpowers in the matrix but neo isn't
able to destroy sentinels because he's
the one it's because he reached the
source prior to the arrival of the
Sentinels at the ending of the Matrix
Reloaded neo explained that he could
feel them before he remotely destroyed
them with his mind by that point neo has
literally established a connection with
everything else connected to the source
like the machines themselves he has
essentially joined their wireless
network it's why he's able to navigate
the machine city or see Smith
a vein during their fight Smith is of
the machines connected to the source
justice neo is thanks to that handy
conduit
he doesn't need eyes to kick Smith's but
in the original matrix agent Smith's
character was his job description an
agent for the matrix who aims to police
the populace by stomping down any signs
of rebellion of virus human beings
disease a cancer of this planet after
his encounter with neo however Smith
begins to repel himself and becomes much
scarier and more powerful as a rogue
program than he ever was as an agent in
the second and third movies of the
trilogy neo and Smith become mirror
images of each other with neo gaining a
connection to the matrix through the
source and Smith gaining a connection to
the real world through his override of
Bane's brain if Smith is the matrix's
virus then neo is his natural anti virus
a connection which the Oracle makes
clear during her final talk with neo
when neo Bleu Smith apart at the ending
of The Matrix
he made a massive imprint on the program
as part of the matrixes attempt tube as
the Oracle explained it balanced the
equation Smith gained new attributes
overriding everything in an effort to
combat neo the fact that his spread is
destructive to the matrix doesn't matter
to Smith anymore he's a rogue program
now cut loose from machine control with
his only purpose being to propagate
himself he doesn't know why and doesn't
choose to do it it is quite simply his
purpose when neo arrives at the Machine
City he is met by what is essentially
the collective voice of the machines
well firstly watch's Trinity died for
about 35 minutes you remember that fun
scene anyway in the machine city the
interconnected hive mind adopts a human
face to speak to the first human ever to
set foot inside the city's walls neo
approaches the machines with a deal
he knows that Smith is ravaging the
matrix corrupting everything taking
control of the entire system
the rogue program is a mutual enemy of
both species and neo offers to handle
the program in exchange for one thing
peace by this point in the story the
machines usual plan for the matrix is in
utter disarray neo having made his
choice not to reload the system upon
arriving at the source is now in totally
new territory
he's already broke
Luke but still needs to accomplish two
goals saving humanity from the machines
and saving the machines from Smith if he
fails everyone dies there will only be
Smith when neo enters the matrix for his
gigantic super saiyan battle he doesn't
do it with the goal of beating smith to
death
how could he smith is everywhere and
everyone neo and the prime Smith battle
as Smith's limitless ranks look on but
Neil doesn't best the program in the
fight he doesn't even come close before
finishing him off though Smith has one
final question for neo why do you
persist
because I choose to Smith for all his
power cannot comprehend the concept of
choice he is a creature of purpose
copying himself mindlessly as a force of
corruption a symptom of the matrix
desperately trying to balance itself out
it's Smith not humanity that has become
the virus it's the choice to fight
rather than the fight itself that makes
neo win the battle neo doesn't succeed
by coming out on top he wins by taking
the battle with Smith to the very end
and choosing to sacrifice himself by
letting Smith copy over him the
antivirus cancels out the virus if Smith
had a choice he wouldn't have done it
but Smith doesn't have a choice he only
has purpose and he successfully fulfills
it which is why as he dies all he can
say is that the outcome is not fair
the Matrix series ends not on a
celebration in the real world but on a
moment of reflection among programs
inside the seventh version of the matrix
with Smith destroyed the revived Oracle
sits and waits for the sunrise as the
architect approaches this is what it's
always been about this battle between
two programs again and a yang the cold
philosophy of the architect and the
faith of the Oracle have been driving
the conflict since its beginning and now
they meet in a condition of ceasefire
the series doesn't really explain all
the details of it but kneels the feet of
Smith is ultimately all the result of
the Oracles intervention in the first
movie the Oracle basically serves as
matchmaker between neo and Trinity
telling them it's their destiny to fall
in love is it really though well no if
the sequels make one thing clear it's
that nobody is really destined to do
anything it's all about choice the
Oracles encouragement of neo and
Trinities romance provides the rogue
element that lets neo break out of the
cycle of control when he reaches the
source instead of reloading the matrix
he leaves to be with Trinity forget the
consequences it was Neos choice sure but
it was also part of the Oracles plan
really going to bake your noodle later
on is which is still broken into 5% did
she know it would work no but she
believed and she was right the elements
of love was the one thing the machines
couldn't prepare for one of the most
curious and under explained characters
in The Matrix sequel
is the young girl sati who's treated
with much importance without the why of
it really being explained the daughter
of two programs neo meets inside the
train man's purgatory sati is a program
without purpose Bourne is the result of
love between two individuals in the
machine world such an entity is a
novelty and also useless subject to
deletion which is why satis parents are
trying to shepherd her to shelter
pneumatically sati is the representation
of love a new concept in the machines
love at the end of the series is
ultimately what secures the human's
victory
miios love her Trinity is what drives
him to make the choice to reject
reloading the matrix and instead fight
for a better peace the machine's
inability to comprehend love left them
with that blind spot
allowing neo to go against every logical
choice to make his own choices instead
sati can be seen as the machines way of
trying to make sense of love at the end
of the movie she is essentially what the
machines have decided to let control the
matrix with the architect and Oracle's
conflict being set aside for the system
seventh version this at least is pretty
much confirmed by the beautiful sunrise
sati said she made for neo and is
supported by the new compassionate
approach to the matrix as human
population in the new version you do
that I need the ending of the Matrix
trilogy doesn't see the matrix destroyed
in fact it is renewed rebooted for a
seventh version this time with new rules
as audiences learn via the lengthy
conversation with the architect and the
Matrix Reloaded previous iterations of
the Matrix all built on the flaws of the
previous one fine-tuning the system by
which the machines control humanity both
inside and outside of the matrix
ergo concordantly visa B you know what I
have no idea what the hell I'm saying I
just thought it would make me sound cool
with the piece secured and a new
compassionate approach at hand any human
who desires to depart the matrix will be
allowed to leave certainly some will
stay the matrix is the ultimate virtual
reality game after all but the
conditions of enslavement are no more at
least for now the end of the movie
implies that more cycles may be set to
come as the Oracle explained the peace
between the warring humans and machines
will only last as long as it can the
peace is not guaranteed the architect
makes that clear satis mere existence is
proof that the machines are now working
to understand this little thing called
love letting her steer the ship while
they observe and learn maybe at some
point forces within the matrix will
figure out how to use love against
humanity and enslave them again until
then it's a beautiful morning in the
matrix and beyond check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our You Tube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you